even if we have no interest at all in
becoming a hindu
hinduism offers us at least four
fascinating ideas
one look forward to death
hinduism is hugely radical in suggesting
that there is nothing especially noble
or interesting about being alive
once we look at matters dispassionately
a lot of what we have to go through is
misery and suffering
we need with great effort to grow up to
assume responsibilities to master a
profession to have a family to take our
place in societies full of backbiting
and hypocrisy to watch those we love get
ill and eventually to succumb to old age
ourselves
to think highly of life is through a
hindu lens a fundamental intellectual
error as hinduism sees it our real
purpose is to be done with life forever
that is the true summit of existence
hinduism reverses the western equation
the sinful and blinkered are forced to
live forever
the righteous and awakened are
privileged enough to be able to die
if we are not careful if we do not show
sufficient mercy and imagination towards
others we may well hinduism suggests be
subjected to the ultimate punishment
we will have to carry on into eternity
the symbol of this ghastly ongoingness
is the eight-spoked wheel of samsara
which evokes the pitiless and unceasing
nature of life to which we are committed
unless we take a disciplined series of
averting actions which together comprise
the central components of hindu ethics
hinduism does not suggest that we will
carry on forever in our own bodies
according to the process of samsara we
are reborn into a succession of
different outward envelopes
as each example is eroded away and
disintegrated by time
because samsara is at work across the
whole animal kingdom we might find our
enduring soul atman
trans migrates at our death into the
body of a woodlouse a pelican or a house
spider though we might also be reborn as
a pediatric nurse or the president
what determines the quality of the
migration is the degree of karma or
virtue that we have accrued in our lives
among the many reasons why we might have
to be kind to others is an awareness
that unkindness might wind us up having
to suffer a cycle or two of life as a
cockroach or a naked mole rat
the suspicion that life is constantly
painful and anxious is one that we
largely have to bear in a very lonely
way in the philosophies of the west
in those of the east pessimism is
ennobled and takes center stage
we are permitted to feel weary and amply
dissatisfied
we have without quite knowing it been
alive since the start of creation and it
is untenably exhausting and frustrating
the trick and the true prize will be to
be good and wise enough to learn to die
once and for all
to rejoin cosmic totality
for hindus the way to step off the
treadmill of eternal existence is to
realize that despite many appearances to
the contrary however paradoxical or
absurd the idea might sound we and the
universe are in truth one
from the earliest age we tend to assume
the very opposite
it seems self-evident that we are one
kind of thing and the tree over there
the relative over here the clouds in the
sky the monkey on the parapet and the
river winding its way to the sea belong
to quite different categories
yet hinduism insists that our belief in
difference belongs ultimately to a realm
of maya or illusion
if we look more deeply into the nature
of things we stand to discover the
remarkable unity of all elements
unlike what appearances imply
everything we can see and experience
around us belongs to the same life force
the leaves unfurling on the tree the
child learning to read the earthworm
digging its tunnels the lava bubbling
from the earth
all belong to a single unitary power
which only egoistic prejudice has
hitherto prevented us from acknowledging
as one
most of our pain hinduism argues arises
from an over-eager attachment to the
difference between ourselves and the
rest of the world
we pay inordinate attention to who has
slightly more money or respect than we
do we are constantly humiliated by
people and events that don't seem to
honor our sense of uniqueness but in a
process known as moksha or liberation we
can throw off the veil of illusion that
works to separate us from the universe
and can start to identify with cosmic
totality
it no longer matters exactly where we
end and others begin everything belongs
to the same hole that we have mistakenly
and unnecessarily carved up into parts
there is a little less reason to grasp
to be puffed up to be proud or to become
embittered
we can survey the course of our lives
and of our societies with calm
indifference
we can cease to identify happiness with
the working out of our will upon the
world and can take in with compassion
and serenity whatever destiny throws our
way
we enjoy paripuma brahma nabhava
the experience of oneness with brahman
the principle of all things
once we have let go of our own ego like
this we may have a few more years left
to live but we can be sure that
eventually we will not need to keep
returning
constant rebirth is the fate of those
who cleave too tightly to their own
selves
by contrast those who have learned to
surrender can at their demise merge with
the universe and will never need to
suffer the indignities of individual
life again
three don't forget money
we might expect that a religion devoted
to spiritual enlightenment would have
scant concern for money and possessions
but hinduism surprises and challenges us
by suggesting that what it calls arter
or a concern for material prosperity has
a place within a wise life
hinduism is not directing us towards
crass materialism
it doesn't want to exhaust us with
overly rich foods or attention-seeking
displays of wealth
but it is aware that many good and
elevated things require a degree of
financial support in order to go well
one won't be able to undertake spiritual
exercises unless one is able to take a
considerable amount of time off from
practical duties every day
meditation on nothingness can be
substantially assisted by having a
servant or two to take care of the
laundry and housekeeping
hindus traditionally direct their hopes
for material comfort to lakshmi the
goddess of prosperity one of the most
popular of all hindu deities she is
typically represented holding two lotus
flowers that speak of spiritual
liberation as well as material good
fortune
she is usually accompanied by at least
one elephant a symbol of power and
strength and a swan an animal that is at
home both in the air and in the water
and thereby speaks of an ability to
combine competence in the material and
spiritual realms
lakshmi understands and would never
condem one's appetite for a better house
or a more high-paying job
her role isn't to make us feel guilty
about wanting more wealth
it is to remind us that the true point
of money is in the end to enable us to
forget about money
4. don't turn against sex
we have come to expect very little in
the way of encouragement or sympathy in
relation to sex from religions
at best a blind eye
at worst a constant hounding and
reminder of the evils of the flesh
but hinduism surprises us
it made the remarkable step of placing
sexual fulfilment karma
among the four purushatas or aims of
human life alongside dharma morality
arthur prosperity
and moksha
spiritual liberation
hinduism's respect for sex was rooted in
a particular understanding of what lies
behind our erotic feelings
these do not stem as has so often been
alleged from a base animal impulse
they are a means by which we can sense
the unity of the
universe normally we live beneath a veil
of illusion which persuades us of the
separateness of all things bodies
included but our sexual desires push us
to break down the barriers between
ourselves and others we might
colloquially say that we are turned on
but through a hindu lens at the core of
our excitement is the sense that we are
breaking down the illusion of
separateness
and taking a small but important step
towards oneness with what we can without
exaggeration following the religion term
the universe
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life
click now to learn more
you